so right but were you able to make a
living and live off of what you were
doing on the 10 albums oh I guess you
had live performing and you had that no
I mean it wasn't nothing I mean it was
it was you know it was enough to live
off of but you know I certainly you know
didn't uh you know I wasn't rich I
wasn't making a lot of money there was a
brief window of time like in the mid 90s
where I actually had a good record deal
and people were still buying records you
know and they're so like I made most of
my money like between 1996 and 1998 I
think right and right now it's a problem
I don't really understand the music
business that much but you know at the
time or at those times people were
buying records and you can make money in
buying records and now people are and
you seem to have pivoted to digital so
they so they can stream and download is
that is that uh is that lucrative well
you know it's it's mostly I mean to this
day I make most of my money uh through
touring and merchandise I mean I make
some money uh from from recordings but
um it's you know it's streaming is very
little you know you hear about people
like oh I had five billion streams I
made 300 you know right it's it's not a
you know it's not nothing but it's not
what it should be and do you continue to
um Listen to I I don't know how you find
like when you used to parody like beat
it was like uh you know it was
everywhere and that was everybody knew
that was the hit I find that now with uh
you know
um Spotify and things like that you've
got you have your own you couldn't be
very com compartmentalized yeah exactly
where I don't know what Top 40 is
anymore well that's one of my other big
problems now I mean um uh back in the
80s there was more of a like a
monoculture like everybody watched MTV
everybody knew what the hits were a lot
of the radio stations are playing the
same thing and now yeah there's all
these uh options uh so if you're into a
very specific sub-genre of music you can
listen to that satellite radio Channel
or just focus laser focus on whatever
you really really like which is good
it's good in a way but also you know I
miss the day of top 40 radio when you
could listen to a channel and be exposed
to Country and R B and rock and you know
everything and I think it you know made
us as a culture a bit more well-rounded
and I I kind of miss those days
and it makes it harder for you to kind
of choose something that's gonna but
though there are things that rise to the
top of course I can't imagine what a
parody and Ali Yankovic parody of wet
ass with me
that'd be better as a polka maybe yeah
that's actually done done
but it should just I don't but there are
things that do rise to the top are you
still writing are you still releasing
not as much a bit I mean I I haven't
really done any uh straight up parodies
for a while but I've done some original
songs there's a new original song in the
movie uh and and you know every now and
then so I haven't been to look super
prolific since my last album came out
I've been uh you know working on the
movie working various other projects and
touring a lot uh so I I haven't stopped
doing it but I've just slowed down and
do you like doing original songs that
you write as equally or do you like that
better than having to do a parody is
there more I like them both I mean there
are two different mindsets
um and do doing the the parodies uh is
not as much work because you don't have
to write the music obviously but there's
sort of more pressure because uh people
really attach a lot of importance to
like a new Weird Al parody
um so it's a bit of a trade-off but but
lately I've been writing more originals
just because I get you know asked to do
various projects like John Oliver asked
me to write a a song uh for for uh uh
North Korea to ask them not to not to
bomb us right I did that and uh uh uh
lin-manuel Miranda had me do the
Hamilton polka yeah uh so I've done a
few projects here and there but um you
know I've got I've got a lot of time
after this next tour so maybe I'll I'll
figure out something new but these guys
are calling you and asking you to do
things you went from like the the the
um The Fringe to you are like mainstream
and that's amazing and not only that and
relevant at this point after all these
years it's been over 40 years also for
you yeah it's kind of strange for me to
to be considered part of the mainstream
because I started out as such an
outsider like this this Punk kid like
making fun of all the people on the on
the in the Inner Circle you know you're
the Inner Circle and yeah I'm good in
the same parties in the award shows and
I'm like rubbing elbows with the people
are making fun of so it's a little
better than just in Dynamics yeah yeah
of course of course does your kid want
to do this no
[Music]